Braid has been to America to the Oakridge national lab.
And he's been through a real treasure trove of elements,
elements I've never seen. And I'm so you haven't as well.
Plutonium neptunium, I'm a risk Siham California.
That's going to be used to make element 119 and lots more.
So I'm going to take you on the Safari through these elements so you can
see them just like I've seen them for the first time for a Safari.
You need the guide.
And our guide is a really experienced chemist Rose bowl.
I'm amazed by what she knew.
What was really interesting is that most of these are isotopically pure.
So we began with uranium two, three, four,
the oxide it's black, but it's uranium.
Then the plutonium I've never seen plutonium
except in solution.
And here there was plutonium as an oxide
solid,
but lots of different bottles each with a different isotopically pure
plutonium. These heavy elements have lots of different isotopes.
They had plutonium from two 39 to two 42.
So that's two 39,
two 42 41 to 42 each in a separate
bottle.
I suspect there may be nowhere else in the world that they have samples like
that. And then there was a sample of uranium, two, three,
three as a bonus. So there was this line of bottles.
I just couldn't believe it. The neptunium,
which they also showed us is adult powder.
The next sample that Brady was shown was Amaris team two, four,
three, which is really very radioactive.
They got quite excited and they were a bit nervous.
So it was only taken out to its led container very briefly.
So how much is that reading?
That's reading about 800 MRR per hour.
That's very hot. Yes.
And it has an activity of 800 million reds now,
which is a lot,
they had 250 milligrams of this americium it
costs $8,000 to ship one milligram.
So you can work out how much it would cost to ship the lots of this material.
8,000 times, 250.
You guys are pretty keen to put that away.
Most of the oxides at black,
but protactinium oxide is white.
This is protecting him two, three.
This is a two to seven sample.
So this one has a 20 year half-life.
I was quite taken with the sample back tenure,
partly because we couldn't see it on the video because
it is so radioactive that the radiation has discolored the
glass in the bottle.
So the transparent glass has gone Brown and you can't see what's inside the
bottle,
but you can tell it's there because it's just gone Brown where the sample is,
the sample itself is white, but we can't see it.
This.
At union with a really nice green,
I suspect the tip was nice, agreed to the naked die.
Then it looked on the video in dilute solution.
It was quite pale, but in a more concentrated solution,
which they only had the tiny amount, it was pretty dark green.
I think it is quite surprising that the salts of these act tonight's
a colored because somehow with all these names at the bottom of the periodic
table, one,
doesn't imagine that some of them might be colored salts,
colored solutions. They sort of simple, boring, and gray,
and you don't really think about them.
But then Rose took Brady to a filing cabinet,
had a lock on it so that people couldn't open it,
except with the combination.
An insight was a whole treasure trove of different samples.
There was technetium 99.
Yeah.
Hello. Technetium 99.
This is very interesting because technetium has different
isotopes 99, the so-called Mehta stable one,
which is used for medical imaging and this one,
which has a much longer half life, about 20 years.
And so it's quite stable and they can keep it in the drawer for a long time.
So you might ask, first of all,
why do people get so excited about such small samples of
material? And the answer is they're highly radioactive,
so they're very dangerous,
but for the applications such as smoke alarms
with Amaris SIM or treating cancer,
because you only need a few particles to do your job,
you need very, very small amounts of the material.
So a milligram of a chemical normally would be such a small amount
that you could hardly use it.
A milligram of these highly radioactive materials can be
really useful. In fact, for some cancer treatments,
you need only a nanogram. That's a millionth of a milligram.
All these samples have been extracted from material that has been
irradiated in nuclear reactors.
Some of them have been leftover. They are,
if you'd like harvesting it from nuclear waste,
which would otherwise just be stored. Others,
especially made by irradiating a sample
in a very high flux of neutrons.
And then you generate the element you want. In fact,
we're going to show you a really nice video soon,
which shows how these elements are made.
This is a plutonium sample. This one is, um,
around 17% for you, two 44.
So it has more plutonium, two 44 than, than most, uh,
plutonium samples. This is a lot of plutonium in at this. Uh,
so it's very concentrated in opposed to the neptunium we looked at earlier,
if this was more dilute than you would see more of the green color,
but this is a very dark green because of how concentrated this plutonium
material is.
You hold this material up to the glove ports and look at it directly through the
side of the glove port. And it's not through the shield shielding.
You can see the color of the material. The shielding gives everything,
a yellow tent, and that's because of the leaded glass and, uh,
polymer plates that we have.
I was quite interested in the sample of protactinium because it turns out that
it doesn't dissolve very well. So it looks green nation solution,
but it looks cloudy a bit like a mixture of green ink.
This is a holmium one 60 6:00 AM.
Holmium one 66 Mehta stable.
It's a solid and it's and you can tilt it on the side or whatever,
so he can kind of see it. It's got a pinkish color to it helped me.
Oxide is a whitish pink solid.
It's much prettier to my eye than it is on the camera.
Like it's a very pretty color that like sort of a salmony. Yeah.
How would you describe that color? Rose I've always called it pink.
No, the samples that really excited me were California.
First of all, there was California two, four nine,
which was again a sort of greenish color.
And they were really quite respectful for that. They,
it was very radioactive. They called it very dosing.
I got it. I got it.
I think that's a really nice word,
a new scientific term for you they've seen,
but then there was California two, five, two, and five one,
which is the material that is going to be used to make the target in the
experiments to try and synthesize elements 119 and
120 in Duke. Now in Russia,
you may remember the time I took you with Brady to Dubner to
see where these new elements are going to be made.
Now you can see what they're going to be made from.
As you know, element one, one,
three Niho Niamh was synthesized in Japan,
Rose produced the sample of Curium two, four eight,
which was used to make the targets for
the work in Japan that synthesized [inaudible]. So the targets were, all of
these elements, experiments are being made at the Oak Ridge national lab. And then in a terrific example of international collaboration
of
being sent all over the world to the accelerators where the elements can be synthesized.
There's only about 17 milligrams in there, so it's not a lot of material.
So it's very hard to see the solid,
but you can tell where it is by the red damage.
So the final question is why should you be so excited by seeing these things?
And the answer is that what you're seeing is a good fraction of
the world's supply of these elements.
You can't ever see all the gold or all the iron in the world,
but here in that lab,
there was the maturity of the samples of these elements.
There may be one or two other labs in the world that have similar
amounts,
but you've seen a really big fraction of the total in
existence of these elements.
Of it later. Some of the material we work with is very highly radioactive.
And so we need shielding to protect us from the dose that comes from that
material. So we work with it with remote handles.